[Música]
mientras los ataques siguen en el
donbass varios lugares de ucrania
vuelven a la normalidad después de que
las tropas rusas se retiraran es el caso
del suburbio de lucha que fue el teatro
de una masacre de civiles a principios
de mayo
francia enfrenta una crisis sanitaria
ante la escasez de personal físico al
punto que muchos hospitales redujeron
sus horarios de urgencias algunos
médicos y enfermeros están en huelga
para exigir mejoras
tres colombianos hacen parte de las 100
personas más influyentes del mundo según
la revista 'time' dos de ellas son
integrantes del movimiento causa justa
que con su demanda lograron la
despenalización del aborto en colombia
hablamos con una de ellas ana cristina
gonzález
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle empezamos a
este informativo en ucrania mientras los
ataques continúan en el donbass otros
lugares de ucrania vuelven a la
normalidad después de que las tropas
rusas se retiraran así ocurre en la
región de kiev concretamente en el
suburbio de butch a allí se reabrió el
mercado y los habitantes intentan
superar las imágenes de la guerra es que
allí hay más de 300 cuerpos fueron
encontrados en fosas comunes o tirados
en las calles andrés granadillo tiene la
historia
paso a paso renace la vida en mucho con
una relativa normalidad en el mercado
los dueños reabren sus puertas
las tiendas se están abriendo poco a
poco las personas con niños pequeños y
perros están regresando es como antes
las carreteras se están reparando poco a
poco todo vuelve a la vida estamos muy
contentos de verlo entonces como digo si
no ves las ruinas prácticamente nos
estamos recuperando de todo esto
[Música]
los clientes aparecen de manera tímida
es un shock al principio y después te
das cuenta de que es nuestra realidad y
necesitas cambiar tu vida y seguir
viviendo la vida sigue y tienes que
vivir sea lo que sea la vida sí porque
siendo no aceptas te vuelves loco es
verdad la vida no debe detenerse está
claro que hay que recuperarla es
realmente muy doloroso lo que los rusos
nos han hecho y nunca ninguna generación
les perdonará esto docenas de nuestras
generaciones recordarán hasta la muerte
atrás quedaron las imágenes honoríficas
que fue el asedio ruso dejando el
cementerio de la ciudad abarrotado tras
su retirada de la ciudad del 31 de marzo
cientos de cuerpos estaban tirados en
las calles rusia niega que haya atacado
a civiles y acusa a ucrania de orquestar
una propaganda en su contra el
secretario general de la onu en su
visita a finales de abril instó al crema
a cooperar con la corte internacional de
justicia
escribe desde guerra cometidos por sus
tropas cuando invadió mucha cambiamos de
noticia en francia hay una crisis
sanitaria por la escasez del personal
clínico ante la cantidad de pacientes
muchas veces éstos no son atendidos o se
ven obligados a esperar durante horas
incluso algunos hospitales recortaron
los horarios de urgencias y el país
arrastra el problema sanitario desde
antes de que empezara la pandemia alva
santana tiene la información
confusos y desinformados unos pocos
pacientes esperan a ser atendidos fuera
del hospital universitario de burdeos
pero algunos no lo lograrán ya que ante
la falta de personal médico muchos
hospitales de francia han implantado un
horario reducido para acceder a
urgencias primero los pacientes deben
llamar al servicio 15 del samu que
decide si ingresan o no en función de su
gravedad y sólo entre las 5 de la tarde
y las 10 de la noche entre semana y
hasta medianoche los fines de semana hoy
en día hay muchos pacientes y sobre todo
no hay suficientes cuidadores así que
nos vemos obligados a restringir nuestra
capacidad de acogida y es que según
fuentes médicas el servicio de urgencias
de burdeos tiene una falta de entre el
40 y el 50 por ciento de médicos un
colapso de pacientes una situación que
el sindicato y otros colectivos llevan
advirtiendo desde hace meses
tenemos médicos que expresan ideas
suicidas médicos y cuidadores que se han
suicidado en francia- por esta presión
en otros puntos como en el hospital de
chino prácticamente todos los enfermeros
de urgencias están de baja debido al
agotamiento acumulado si no queda
ninguna enfermera y se empieza con la
reanimación el personal debe elegir qué
vida salvar y eso no es ni siquiera
imaginable en el hospital de lyon los
médicos y enfermeros están en huelga
desde marzo cuando un paciente murió en
un pasillo por el colapso del centro
ahora atienden los casos en los que
peligra la vida
llevamos meses incluso años advirtiendo
de esta desintegración del hospital
público en general y en las urgencias
esta crisis sanitaria es un problema de
fondo en el país y los expertos estiman
que si no se soluciona podría significar
el fin de los servicios de urgencias en
unos años pasamos a américa latina en
menos de una semana los colombianos
votarán para elegir al presidente las
encuestas muestran que el candidato
gustavo petro podría ser el más votado
este domingo 29 de mayo uno de nuestros
equipos viajó hasta ciénaga de oro el
pueblo natal del izquierdista
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no es una estrella del rock es gustavo
petro quieres ser presidente de colombia
y hace campaña en el pueblo en el que
nació
ciénaga de oro donde hasta los ciegos
bailan por verle
[Aplausos]
el evento se llama petro escucha los
asistentes le plantean propuestas
como diana varela representante de un
grupo de mujeres cocineras
tomando mate en grande lo tengo en
frente de mí
[Música]
ciénaga de oro es un municipio cerca del
mar caribe ilusiona a la posibilidad de
tener el primer presidente del
departamento de córdoba
los orígenes de gustavo petro son
humildes y sus primos enseñan la casa en
la que nació hoy es la sede del partido
al poco de nacer gustavo se fue a vivir
cerca de bogotá pero nunca dejó de
volver
él era de pocas palabras muy tímido pero
las pocas conversaciones que forjaba con
uno tenía esa orientación de líder
y es probable que contenga alguna en la
zona también quedan viejos compañeros de
lucha vaché rodríguez perteneció la
extinta guerrilla del m-19 a la que
petro se incorporó en 1977 se
desmovilizaron en 1990 tras un acuerdo
de paz petro representa los valores del
m-19 expresado en
paz
justicia trabajo y democracia hoy
tuviera 60 años de edad pero más de 30
años después muchos no olvidan su pasado
gustavo laca es médico y fue alcalde de
ciénaga de oro en dos ocasiones
a su hermano lo mató el m-19
los criminales no son ex criminales bien
los criminales háganse siempre
criminales
gustavo petro acaba la jornada con un
mitin y
rodeado de seguridad y acompañado por
miles de fieles pretende romper con la
historia para convertirse en el primer
presidente de izquierda de colombia
tres colombianos hacen parte de las 100
personas más influyentes del mundo según
la revista 'time' y dos de ellas son
mujeres ana cristina gonzález y cristina
villarreal entraron en el famoso listado
en la categoría de pioneros por sus
esfuerzos para que en colombia se
despenalizara el aborto en todas las
causales y hasta la semana 24 desde
bogotá dan a cristina gonzález nos contó
cómo su labor da esperanza a los
derechos reproductivos en eeuu un país
donde se podría prohibir el aborto
pues me parece increíble que haya que
exista digamos este reconocimiento a los
feminismos del sur global yo creo que
los feminismos en américa latina' además
tenemos una tradición de encuentro de
acumulación política de compartir
estrategias
ideas formas de discutir de movilizarnos
en las calles con siempre de manera
pacífica digamos y abriendo
conversaciones democráticas entonces lo
tomo como un reconocimiento a la
centralidad que tiene este tema de la
libertad en dos sentidos uno en tener
democracias más sólidas y más firmes y
democracias y sociedades mejores que
reconozcan la ciudadanía plena a las
mujeres
yo creo que pues en este momento que
puede ser muy lamentable para la
historia de eeuu porque imagínense
ustedes que un buen día se despierten y
les digan que ya no pueden votar
eso les podría pasar a las mujeres en
eeuu sin embargo la conquista de los
derechos que es muy importante en el
plano legal también ocurre en el plano
de lo que nosotros llamamos la
legitimidad social y estoy segura que
las mujeres en estados son conscientes
de que tienen ese derecho a que se les
respete su libertad reproductiva y vamos
de aquí en adelante intercambiar desde
el sur hacia el norte estrategias para
ayudar a que este retroceso no cobre las
vidas de mujeres como realmente es lo
que sucede en este tipo de situaciones
así llegamos al final de las noticias
sigan con nosotros en france 24
[Música]